- So in the early debates
about the Constitution,
there are folks that wanted
a strong central leadership
and other folks who didn't,
because they felt it felt
a lot like George III.
How did the existence of
Washington as a person
affect the debate?
- It's amazing.
So George Washington, his
friends have to plead with him
to come to the Constitutional Convention.
He thinks, frankly,
that rewriting the rules
of the country, it's not gonna work.
But they finally convince him to come
and they make him president
of the convention.
And they put him at the front of the room,
and he says almost nothing
during the entire four months.
But what he does is at the
front of the room he is a model,
because, remember, he
resigned his commission
as commander of the Continental
Army and gave up power.
He didn't seize the power that he had as,
he was basically the biggest
celebrity in America,
and he gave his commission
back to the government,
which was an act of sublimating
his own personal self interest
for the benefit of the republic.
And that's the model they
wanted for the Constitution.
So he didn't say much, but
they designed basically,
as one writer said that what
they were essentially doing
was writing his future job description,
because everybody in the
room knew he would ultimately
become the president,
because there was nobody
else in America like him.
And what was important was
not that he was a general,
but that he had this virtue inside of him,
which was that he would know how far to go
and when to stop, and when
to protect those liberties.
And so he sat on a chair
with a sun on the back of it,
and at the end of the proceedings,
Benjamin Franklin, who was
the only other great, kind of,
superstar in America who
participated in the convention
said that he looked at that
sun on Washington's chair,
and he wasn't sure whether
it was a rising sun
or a setting sun,
but now after they finished their work,
he had decided that the sun was rising,
which was basically anointing
and blessing everything
that had happened there,
and this new office of
presidency that they had created,
that George Washington
was to go walk into,
and that's why Washington's statue
is in front of Independence Hall
where the Constitutional
Convention took place.
But in the dialogue over four months,
you almost never see his words.
He was there as a symbol and participant,
but not like James
Madison, or James Wilson,
or Gouverneur Morris who were
in there in the nitty gritty
of every little detail.
- Do we know what Washington was thinking,
did he want the job, did he have a view,
or he just said,
"Hey, I'm just gonna do
what everyone else decides"?
- Fortunately, they did
everything in secret.
Washington was so virtuous
that he didn't even write
about it in his diary.
Now, fortunately, we have other
people who did keep diaries,
and James Madison took notes and said,
"Publish them only after
all 55 members are dead."
What Washington thought is he
wanted a central government,
because as a general he
knew there had to be an army
to handle rebellions,
and there had been Shays' Rebellion
that had tested under the
Articles of Confederation.
So he wanted a strong government,
but he was, and he was very worried
that having been
successful revolutionaries,
they could do what he
knew was hard by history,
which is that revolutionaries
aren't very good
at creating governments.
And so he knew that what they were doing
was a real risk and a real gamble.
He believed that it
could be done, however.
He believed that a strong
national government was required.
But then was he was given the job,
he was incredibly nervous,
this incredible military
leader basically thought
that he might fail.
It was more likely than not
that this whole darn thing
would fail and that he might fail.
And as he rode to his inauguration,
he kept writing letters and in his diary
talking about how the
expectations of his countrymen
were just too much for him.
And that was both a personal worry,
and he also worried about monarchy.
How does monarchy build?
It's either when a monarch demands power
or when the mob hands all
of the power to the person
and says, "Do everything for us,"
and gives them ultimate power.
And what they knew in the
convention was that human beings
were sinful and could not handle power.
If they were given the
power, they would abuse it
as surely as the sun
comes up in the morning.
And he was worried that
if given too much power,
perhaps he could be susceptible to that.
And so he was for as confident
and as much of a model
of strength that he was,
he was a very nervous guy.
- And it sounds like an
unusual person where the power,
at least as the history I've read,
didn't corrupt him and he
didn't try to do a power grab.
- That's right, Washington was constantly,
he was a man of a rigid code,
and he believed that the
standards were necessary
for the proper kind of human behavior.
He wrote a list of a
hundred different things
that a gentleman should
do to comport himself
in the proper way in society,
and that's what made
him such a good model.
- I'd like a copy of that.
- (laughs) Yes, exactly.
- I have a feeling
I don't check most of them off. (laughing)
- We'd all be better.
But things like clearing your throat,
how you behave in the presence of a lady.
And he believed in these codes,
because he believed if
everybody maintained them,
then the system would work.
This was during the
period where Newton's laws
were making people think
about a clockwork universe
where if everything runs,
if the machine is put
together with tension, right,
so it recognized that
people were not angels,
tension in the machine,
but if everybody did their thing
and the pieces stayed in
their lane, as it were,
then the clock would work.
And so he had that code
which tried to keep him
in his place and keep
everybody else in his place,
and he set a standard,
and then everybody tried to live up to it,
as opposed to saying,
"Well, that standard's nice,
"but I'm now gonna go do this."
And that's why when he resigned
his military commission,
and he also undid a coup that
some of his men were planning
back when he was leader of the army.
They were basically gonna
go to Congress and say,
this is in Newburgh, New York,
they were gonna go to Congress and say,
"Unless you give us our money,
"we're gonna stage a coup."
He found out about the plot,
went to his men and said,
"This is a sin both against the revolution
"and my own personal virtue,
"because I put myself on the line."
They backed off.
And what he coulda done is say,
"Let's go, let's ride to
Washington and get you your money.
"You fought in this war.
"Your wives and children
are begging and poor.
"You deserve this money.
"Let's use our power and
authority and take it,"
and he said, "No."
Joseph Ellis, the
historian, writes about it
as being the last temptation
of Washington as a general.
He has the chance to grab the power,
and he says, "No, we shouldn't do it."
And that's why he was a model,
because he could resist the pull of power,
and that's the image in
which they wanted to create
this new government.
- Wow.